today's episode is sponsored by dashlane
you've probably heard of identity
protection password managers and VPNs
but there you have them are you using
them well if not you certainly should be
and the best way to do that is with
dashlane which is a one-stop shop for
all of your digital identity protection
needs if your passwords are the same
that's a bad idea you can use - Lane's
password manager to create and securely
store complex and unique passwords
making it less likely that your accounts
are going to be compromised they also
have a VPN as part of their service
meaning that you can browse the Internet
securely and confidently even on public
Wi-Fi plus dashlane does what it's
always done it stores your passwords it
keeps your personal data secure it fills
all of those annoying boxes for payment
info and passwords for you a lot of
dashlane is free but there are some
premium upgrades and you can buy those
if you want but the first 200 people can
enjoy an exclusive 10% off - Lane
premium with the discount code visual
politik which you can use at dash Lane
comm forward slash visual politics to
protect yourself right now and let's get
into today's video I regret the day I
said yes to mr. trunk I regret all the
help and support
I gave him along the way I am ashamed of
my own failings February the 27th 2019
Michael Cohen Donald Trump's lawyer and
trusted sidekick for the last decade
appeared before the US Congress his
statement was a bombshell against the
president's Kevin accused Trump of
cooperating with Russia during the
election campaign as well as several tax
crimes he also described to Donald Trump
as a racist a con man and a cheat I am
ashamed because I know what mr. Trump is
he is a racist he is a con man and he is
achieved you know a little impressed by
that frankly could have he could have
gone all out he only went about 95
percent instead of a hundred percent
so Devo ah Michael Kern was talking
about Donald Trump the president of the
United States himself was thousands of
kilometers away from Washington on a
trip in her Nonie the Vietnamese capital
to meet with the North Korean leader Kim
jong-un in what was the second summit
between the two leaders but I think
having a fake hearing like that and
having it in the middle of this very
important summit is really a terrible
thing this is a summit that has been
dismissed by most of the media as a
failure and this leaves us with a big
question well was the Hanoi summit
really a failure where exactly did the
negotiations between the United States
and North Korea ends up well let's take
a look
alright so there are some exceptions but
generally sequels never as exciting as
the original right control well it looks
like something similar happens in Hanoi
just eight months after the historic
first meeting in Singapore donald trump
and kim jeong-hoon they saw each other
again expectations at this time a
concrete agreement would be reached with
deadlines goals and objectives however
antonyms happen the summit ended hastily
without any specific understanding on
the one hand North Korea demanded that
all international sanctions be
eliminated in exchange for dismantling
its main nuclear complex not the only
one it has the young beyond complex safe
center dedicated to the production of
plutonium and uranium fuel for North
Korea's nuclear weapons on the one hands
the United States demanded that North
Korea take the first step dismantling
all of its nuclear programs production
and development centers including all
the clandestine centers after this they
would contemplate lifting the
international sanctions
as you can see their positions weren't
entirely compatible North Korea didn't
want to give up its nuclear program in
the United States wasn't willing to make
concessions at all the dilemma that we
were confronted with is the North
Koreans at this point are unwilling to
impose a complete freeze on their
weapons of mass destruction programs so
to give many many billions of dollars in
sanctions relief would in effect put us
in a position of subsidizing the ongoing
development of weapons of mass
destruction in North Korea a State
Department officials speaking to The
Washington Post but don't think this
came as a surprise it's true Donald
Trump did seem very upbeat thinking that
in exchange for guaranteeing a splendid
future for North Korea with investments
and economic developments it managed to
convince Kim jong-un to change his ways
I'll check this out our United States
team has arrived in North Korea to make
arrangements for the summit between Kim
jong-un and myself I truly believe North
Korea as brilliant potential it'll be a
great economic and financial nation one
day Kim jong-un agrees with me on this
it will happen Donald Trump but the
truth is that his team was much less
optimistic North Korea will seek to
retain its WMD capabilities and is
unlikely to completely give up its
nuclear weapons and production
capabilities because its leaders
ultimately view nuclear weapons as
critical to regime survival
both Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and
national security adviser john bolton
have expressed their doubts about being
able to reach an agreement
the fact is that this is what every
media source has been told and is the
reason why the summit was considered a
true failure but hold on a second
because the question we want to answer
is well was it really a failure well
yeah it kind of was but also know
if you'e let's be upfront about this on
visual politic we don't exactly
sympathize with Donald Trump but we
always want to be objective which is not
the same as being neutral so we believe
that we can give you three reasons why
the summit's unlike what most of the
media have said wasn't an absolute
failure so listen up objective Vietnam
although it often goes unnoticed with
more than 90 million inhabitants Vietnam
has not only become one of the fastest
growing economies in the world in the
last three decades but it's also become
increasingly important to the United
States yes it may be surprising but
these two countries that less than half
a century ago worth protagonists of one
of the longest and harshest wars in
history and out to significant economic
and political partners
you're more proof of this tight
relationship in March of 2018 the
aircraft carrier USS Carl Vinson set
sail for four days in Danang it was the
first visit to Vietnam by a US military
ship since the end of the war in 1975
the point is that Donald Trump's visit
it didn't have only one goal but rather
to allow me to explain the White House
took advantage of this trip to
strengthen its ties with the Vietnamese
government Trump met both the presidents
and the Prime Minister and presided over
a symbolic act in which several
Vietnamese airlines commissioned more
than twenty billion dollars to purchase
aircraft and services from American
companies in particular Boeing in
addition they mapped out free trade
agreements and the sale of billions of
dollars of military equipments that's
because the United States wants to turn
Vietnam into one of its most important
partners in this area of the world both
politically and economically why well
because Vietnam is growing by leaps and
bounds
further it's very open to trade it's got
unfriendly relations with China and its
workforce has very low labor costs in
other words it's a perfect country to
flood with dollars although I'm not sure
how chumps are going to cope with the
fact that the United States has a trade
deficit with Vietnam of almost forty
billion dollars for its part Vietnam
aims to receive all of those dollars to
accelerate its developments its autonomy
from China and its leadership in
Southeast Asia
I know a is desperate for a better
relationship with Washington and would
like to free-trade agreement with the
Trump administration to ensure it is not
entirely dependent on Chinese markets
and consumers Vietnam also would love to
purchase large amounts of advanced US
military equipment Harry Jake as Yanis
director of Korean studies at the center
for the national interest well what
better way than giving Vietnam the
prominence and political influence of
hosting a summit of this type and if
they also use its strength and Thai as
well that's even better
wouldn't you agree well that's precisely
what happens
cards on the table
in a visual politic video about the
Singapore summit we explained how North
Korea's concepts of what denuclearizing
the Korean Peninsula means and how it's
very different from what the rest of the
world understands
North Korea has no intention of giving
up its nuclear weapons at least not in
such a straightforward way it'll
probably come as no surprise when I say
that the North Korean regime is a cruel
dictatorship with an absolutely
abominable track record when it comes to
human rights isolated from the rest of
the world and ruled with an iron fist by
three generations of the family of the
current leader Kim Jong oh we're talking
about a country where citizens can be
sent to prison for simply watching
reading or listening to international
media it's a country where any dissent
or disagreement about the government's
can lead to brutal re-education and
forced labor camps it's a country with a
state that exploits its own people by
making them work in semi slavery
conditions while despite all of this
Donald Trump's desire to push through
his precious agreements along with his
predilection for dictators and
authoritarian positions glossed over the
true nature of the policies of Pyongyang
everyone's looking out for their own
interests no one's looking out for the
interests of North Korea's citizens Brad
Adams Asia director of Human Rights
Watch be very surprised very smart very
good negotiator really he's got a great
personality he's a you know funny guy
he's a very smart guys a great
negotiator
he loves his people not that I'm
surprised by that but he loves his
people don't let anyone think anything
different he speaks and his people sit
up at attention I want my people to do
the same
while thanks to this failed summers the
cards have remained on the table Kim
Jong Un's regime has no intention of
giving up its power or its nuclear
weapons and let's make this clear
forcing North Korea to acknowledge the
stance publicly actually strengthens the
United States for any future
negotiations now any expectations for
subsequent agreements have drops and
that was needed actually it was a very
productive two days but sometimes you
have to walk washington has gained the
upper hand in the negotiations which
they will continue to flex because they
know North Korea desperately needs to
overcome its sanctions now this all
leads us to our third point
the reforms everything depends on the
reforms folks just thirty years ago
Vietnam was in an even worse situation
than North Korea the country was
shattered by Wars and suffering from a
blockade from China the United States
Europe and even its Southeast Asian
neighbors his economy
it was literally sunk leaving about 70
percent of its inhabitants to live in
extreme poverty since then things
they've changed a lot
today only around 3 percent of Viet
Nam's population lives in extreme
poverty
that's an SIV reduction 70 percent to 3
percent well the fact is that Vietnam
unilaterally implemented its own reform
plan known as the DOE Moy they started
doing this even before they reconciled
with the international community that is
they were doing this while they were
suffering a blockade from the United
States and what could be a better
example for North Korea
what better action to involve Vietnam in
this process and set it up as an example
it's a great way to let Pyongyang know
what they could achieve the success of
the Vietnamese economy is due to its
decision to normalize relations with the
United States in 1995 I would say to our
North Korean friends as long as they
have a conflict with the United States
they will not be able to develop their
economy properly
Major General Wynn LaVon and Cuong
former director of the Institute of
Strategic Studies at the Vietnamese
Ministry of Public Security we told you
in several videos which will link to in
the description that Kim Jong young
seems determined to promote economic
reforms and open North Korea what better
way to persuade him than by showing him
the results firsthand no revolutionary
tasks stand before us other than the
improvement of the economy and people's
daily lives Kim Jong un folks the United
States it seems to know that the North
Korean problem will only be solved with
a new strategy that focuses more on
trade than on weapons maybe the summit
didn't have the expected results but
does that mean it was a failure the
answer is not so clear at first glance
especially if we consider the White
House's new strategy we are not going to
invade North Korea we are not seeking to
topple the North Korean regime we are
ready for a different future it's bigger
than denuclearization I'm absolutely
convinced and more importantly the
president of the United States is
convinced that it's time to move past 70
years of war and hostility on the Korean
Peninsula there is no reason for this
conflict to persist any longer Stephen
our vegan the US Special Representative
for North Korea so what do you think do
you support the Trump administration's
strategy towards North Korea well leave
your answer in the comments below as
well as in this survey and I really hope
you enjoyed this video please do hit
that like button if you did
don't forget to subscribe for brand-new
videos also please do check out our
friends at reconsider media they
provided the vocals in this episode but
were not mine also this video is brought
to you by dashlane for that special
discount please do check them out
through the description below and as
always I'll see you next time
we're very surprised very smart very
good negotiator really he's got a great
personality he's a you know funny guy
he's a very smart guy he's a great
negotiator he loves those people not
that I'm surprised by that but he loves
his people and don't let anyone think
anything different he speaks and his
people sit up at attention I want my
people to do the same